[Musik]
[Applaus]
der dingo 2 was ja ganz nett klingt ist
das ein schutzhaus fahrzeug des
österreichischen bundesheers und es ist
bestens ausgestattet zb mit einem
militärischen gps-system einem
abs-system einer funkanlage und einer
außenputz sprechanlage
[Musik]
das fahrzeug ist relativ einfach zu
bedienen und es besteht aus einer großen
zelle im innenraum die für gefechte und
ambulante einsätze ausgelegt ist
[Musik]
der dingo 2 wird vor allem viel
internationale einsätze häufig verwendet
und er kann trotz seines kant gewichtes
von zwölf toren von speziellen
transportflugzeuge und hubschrauber
transportiert werden
mit dem fahrer haben hier sechs personen
platz das wichtigste ist der schutz der
soldaten und der ist hervorragend der
dingo 2 schützt nämlich vor jeglichen
bedrohungsszenarien wie zum beispiel
langsam in ihren handfeuerwaffen oder
auch abc kampfstoffen also atomare
biologische und chemische waffen
[Musik]